you're a very public figure and your
personal life spills over
and it's created I'm sure a number of
challenges for you this season I think
there's a lot of Professionals in life
that go through things that they deal
with that work and they deal with at
home and obviously the good news is
things that it's a very amicable
situation Tom Brady breaks his silence
about his split from Gisele Bundchen
when I feel like I'm so driven to
succeed in football and that's taken me
away from
other important priorities which are my
kids my wife on his Serious XM podcast
let's go with Tom Brady Larry Fitzgerald
and Jim Gray the NFL quarterback
addresses his divorce and how he's doing
since I'm really focused on two things
and taking care of my family
and certainly my children and secondly
doing the best job I can to win football
games so that's what professionals do
you focus at work when it's time to work
and then when you come home you focus on
the priorities that are at home but for
Tom he says compartmentalizing his home
and work life is a challenge but
regardless the athlete always tries his
hardest we do the best we could do and I
have incredible parents that have always
taught me the right way to do things uh
you know I want to be a great father to
my children and always try to do things
the right way as well and to deal with
things that in your life that have
challenges you want to deal with the in
the best possible way so I want to
always be able to hold my head high on
and off the field and I'm going to try
to continue to do that for as long as
I'm here Tom's comments come just days
after the couple announced they called
it quits after 13 years of marriage in a
statement Giselle wrote in part to quote
the decision to end marriage is never
easy but we have grown apart she's
really held it down for our family and
I'm just super grateful that you know
she really committed so much of her time
the last you know 14 years to make sure
everything was so stable at home so I
could go live my dream the two tied the
knot in 2009 and our parents to 12 year
old Benjamin and nine-year-old Vivian
and when it comes to their split
Rin are there
gazelle says they'll continue
co-parenting to give them the love care
and attention they greatly deserve just
special moments with your family and you
know it's a um you know it's a great
part of my life and you know I take
advantage of it when I can and Tom took
advantage of that over the weekend
teaching his kiddos the importance of
giving back they're just the biggest
blessing each he learned that Tom Vivian
and Benjamin traveled to Port Charlotte
Florida on Sunday where they served food
and helped deliver meals to storm hit
mobile home residents I want to try to
spend my time with when I'm focused on
my job my job when I'm focused with my
family my family and I look back at my
parents and my dad and mom do the same
thing for me so maybe some guilt that I
haven't been able to do that in the same
way for my kids
foreign